he's my buddy Daniel Jeremiah here on
the Rich Eisen show how are you DJ I'm
doing great rich I'm uh I'm in between
practices at the east-west okay I've got
I've got the training a little bit of
tape done on Jacob Eason the quarterback
from Washington right and I've got my
mock draft 1.0 on the computer to my
left as I'm trying to throw that slop
okay now Daniel let's go what do we got
yeah what do we have well we got we
can't give away that we can't give away
the keys to the castle here we've got
this things come on
well I don't wanted to probably post the
early next week DJ 1 & 2 are in bold you
can actually take a sharpie and write it
on your your computer screen and just
leave it there for the next three months
right come on now right yeah that is a
that's a fair point I will I will have
those 1 & 2 from here till the to the
finish line a lot I usually most years I
try and ride the same horse number one
all the way through just to see you know
how it works out some years you know I
think miles Garrett was easy Jameis
Winston I think was another one where I
start to finish you just kind of wrote
it all the way through right I don't
know that I've ever had it where I've
had one and two so I guess maybe you
know what the Goff and once you're
pretty early on you knew those are the
top two picks
after those trades you just didn't know
who was gonna go first that's correct
and Winston is the last player to have
gone ahead and won a national
championship in an undefeated campaign
win a Heisman and then be the first
overall selection in a draft as we
expect Joe burrow to be there's no
chance right that the Bengals don't take
burrow or swap the pick out right DJ
well there's no chance they swap the
tick out because they don't believe in
trading like it that's that's just not
there in their DNA they do not like the
trade they like to use the pick that was
given to them by the Commissioner
whether it's one or 31 or 32 whatever
they get they're going to use that picks
right I don't see them trading and then
you know I look Mike Brown hasn't talked
to a lot of people so he's the one who
ultimately makes that decision and you
know unless he's he's got something else
in mind if they do have something else
in mind it won't get out you talk about
organization where there will be no
leaks there will be no leaks there
tight circle but conventional wisdom and
everybody around the league expects that
to be Joe Burrell one and then
Washington man I've talked to I've got a
lot of friends different teams in the
end the NFC East and man they're saying
this can be a quick turnaround in
Washington when you've got chase young
and Montez sweat coming off the edges
pain inside and they've got three other
defensive tackles that are really good
that's got a chance to be a dominant
front and it to me is a blueprint
counted at the 49ers have set for them
and then
so Daniel Jeremiah here in the Rich
Eisen show when when we heard about
again chase young coming out that day
that we heard chase young coming out and
I'm like okay now you go you've won you
got your - to me the Detroit Lions are
sitting in the catbird seat because
we're assuming Stafford's gonna be
coming back and looking like the
Stafford pre back injury this year and
he was having a dynamite campaign so the
Lions can sit back and say who wants to
aright who wants to o and raise their
hands assuming that again everything is
fine with - oh that the Lions are kind
of the domino the first domino in the
2020 draft that we're going to be
focusing on from here all the way
through to opening night what do you say
to that sir
yeah we'll be in Vegas but the draft
starts in Detroit so that to me is where
the where the fun really begins and you
know I look I think they need to find
out the Stafford is going to be fully
healthy going forward if you're asking
me what I would do I'm sticking with
Stafford I'm auctioning that pic and I'm
I don't want to fall further than the
seventh pick but you've got Miami six or
Miami five Chargers six Carolina seven
who are all quarterback teams and so you
can get a big haul without having to do
what some other teams have had to do and
and drop all the way out of the top ten
you're still in a great position to get
somebody like in Jeffery Okuda from Ohio
State who comes in and helps your
secondary and a boatload of other picks
but I think they at least have to
investigate and say you know look if you
love to us and you think you could
option off Matthew Stafford and get a
king's ransom for him he's older he cost
more money you get to on the cheap and a
bunch of picks you could
start a kind of a new era there in
Detroit so I don't think that's what
they'll do I don't think that's what
they should do but that's something they
still have to discuss why do you say
Panthers are a quarterback needy team I
mean Matt rule and Joe Brady cam doesn't
work there if he's if is what's all good
what do you think DJ III I think a lot
of times rich when you have when you
have the new coaches come in and new
personnel I think though hire GM after
drafts over but it's a new era new owner
a lot of times that the quarterback gets
swept up in that and I just think if you
look at if you watched LSU if you watch
the Saints right and that's where Joe
Brady came from and that's the office
they ran at LSU I did not think cam as a
precision passer I did not think he's a
great fit in that system mm-hmm okay
this is interesting
borrow best quarterback season you've
ever seen yeah your name I kept waiting
for a bad game rich and it never
happened I've never seen yeah to me
touchdowns I mean I don't know how I
mean how do you argue against it I've
never seen anything like that
it's here's the fascination and there
are some people and scout can be
hard-headed rich and he does not have a
huge arm and that's the knock on that so
if you're gonna try and pick them apart
that's the only thing you can do and I
really gave a lot of thought to this and
you know I put a huge grade on these
were all the way up there's going to be
chasing young number one on my board and
Forough be number two but rich when you
think about this the history of the NFL
the all-time leading passer right Drew
Brees would would he win any you know
radar gun contests with an arm strength
no the all-time leading rusher is Emmitt
Smith what he won a 40-yard dash contest
with a lot of running backs during his
day well you're asking the wrong guy
about the 40 but I think I get your
point yes true true and then who's the
all-time leading receiver with you
height weight speed guys right no no sir
these are the greatest to ever do it in
terms of production in the NFL so to get
hung up on not having up irrational on
top to your arm strength I think it's
just silly yeah I mean Brady had the
measurables as we know from the combine
didn't read all the charts either you
know so can I give you a guess can I
give you a guest recommendation for the
Rich Eisen
go for it Daniel Jeremiah yeah what do
you got you need to have Kevin you need
to have Kevin fawlcon
okay all right Kevin Faulk is at LSU
Kevin Faulk has told every scout that
rolls through there Joe Brady is Tom
Brady and nobody would know better than
him so he's been around both guys he'd
be a great person to talk Joe borrow is
Tom Brady you're basically sets with dev
that Falk is telling people well he
would know obviously since he says he's
seen both up close and personal Daniel
Jeremiah here on the Rich Eisen show
who's flashed who of you because I mean
it's amazing well I'm in the middle of
like a bowl game that all of America is
watching and tweeting about and then you
just like to throw something up there
like the boy this kid just I've just
watching some tape while I'm watching
this game it's just I'm like you're like
apropos of nothing this kid is really
terrific and should be flashing in the
combine and in the draft so who do you
who who are you spotlighting right now
I'm not talking about I'll tell you what
here's this time year's fun for me
because you know I try not to read too
much about all this while the other
draft Knicks are throwing out there I do
you know I like to get my own opinion on
these guys and so it is interesting
sometimes though to take the temperature
and kind of see some people that aren't
getting a lot of run and when I watch
them and I might just learn what am I
missing here this guy's a freak there is
an offensive tackle at Louisville named
Makai Beckham who is you know six he's
enormous rich he's six seven 360 370
pounds I'll text you a video of him
Duncan in high school you could see how
much of a freak this guy is but he's
guys like that don't come around very
often man he's gonna be a top-10 pick
he's a big-time big-time player so
you're going left tackle out of
everybody I'm saying who's flashing you
going big-time left tackle for this
draft huh how about that yeah I'll send
you a little snippet of him of him
getting off the floor and dunking a
basketball 360 plus pounds and see what
you think
okay how did he Cleese retirement hit
the scouting community and everybody
else all the evaluators at east-west
Shrine
Daniel you know surprised I think you
know it's a I was bummed because I I
know Dan Morgan a little bit Dan
Morgan's a great guy obviously was a
great player there and then it's really
one of the bright
incoming personnel guys working with the
Buffalo Bills and I talked to him before
this happened so afternoon practice
today I might go try and bend his ear a
little bit and see what he thinks about
that but we have seen now rich a a good
number of Hall of Fame caliber players
decide before the age of 30 or around
that time to shut it down and I think
those decisions are personal but I know
one thing that's are we gonna have to
change a little bit the criteria the
expectation on the Hall of Fame thing I
mean you don't have to play 12 years 13
years to be a Hall of Famer this is this
guy was as good as anybody his position
for a very long time what the eight
years probably is that how long he
played well yeah he played one year
longer than luck you know what I mean
and and and I think that's what you're
driving at here is that the NFL 100
campaign began with the luck retirement
where we weren't we weren't thinking
about that he clearly was although his
issues were not concussive like clearly
key Cleese was I mean the the the night
where we were on Thursday Night Football
and he got his bell rung so badly and
he's crying hysterically leaving the
field and we learned it's not him crying
hysterically because he realized he had
another concussion it might be it's just
that you can't control your emotions
many times when you have been concussed
as many times as he was and it was so
jarring and it was so frightening Daniel
that maybe we do have to start
considering that sort of stuff and I'm
wondering what how that would work
you you are boots on the ground right in
the middle of what we would call the
culture of the NFL so what do you think
I think you're gonna see more of it and
I don't you know look I think he's you
get a chance to have a major impact on
the game you know he went to a Super
Bowl you know all these all pros Pro
Bowls and then he's got them he's got
plenty of money
and they just said that's enough and and
I think look I'm not a doctor I can't
get into the long term you know
situation there with concussions and all
that I I just think that that's it's a
personal decision but I think I'll
you're gonna see it happening more and
more and as they you know from a
personnel side you know standpoint the
way I would look at other people look at
it you can't assume any longer that
you're going to have these guys for you
know 14 15 years you just it's changing
and I don't I don't think it's a bad
thing rich I think they gave tremendous
amount to this game the game gave a
tremendous amount to them and they
decided to move on I go back to Kuechly
when we were talking about him I was
with the Philadelphia Eagles during that
draft and I just pulled it up because I
wanted to make sure that I was right on
this but we thought we thought there
might have been like an error in the
computer system because we had all of
his production rich three years at
Boston College 158 tackles a hundred and
eighty three TAC 191 tackles I mean this
guy I mean not just in the NFL he was in
on every play in college that's a lot of
contact sure is Daniel Jeremiah here on
the Rich Eisen show another sensitive
subject I want to ask you about although
this is not health it involves the
Chargers for whom you've been calling
yeah radio two years now with uh with
money Smith so the quarterback and what
they do at that position and the
possibility that a brady could come here
there's a lot of moving parts here a lot
of spinning plates that might have to be
winding up on on a certain spot for that
to happen how likely do you think this
is happening for the Los Angeles
chargers as they open up a new building
and need to put Fannie's in the seats DJ
yeah I mean I think okay not with any
inside information but it just kind of
it felt almost like the the you know the
kind of the end of a chapter there with
with Phillip Rivers and we'll see what
happens with him but if you're just
saying this kind of my gut my gut would
say and I wouldn't have said this even
of you know two months ago I said I
probably still come back with Phillip
and I can make the case that's maybe the
smart thing for one more year but I
can't envision a scenario where your tie
rod is your one and only going into the
new building and I can't imagine you let
Phillip go unless you could bring in
somebody that's just got a little juice
and that would either have to be
somebody like to ax in the draft or
you're talking about the ultimate juice
there with with the Michigan man and Tom
Brady so that to me seems like the three
options you have it's Philip Rivers it's
to a more it's Tom I mean that sounds
like the name of an album this is Tom
well there's Herbert to this Justin dis
Justin Herbert do you think that would
be sentimental
I don't I don't I know a lot of people
have talked about that I've done a lot
of work a lot more work on him in the
last couple days I don't I don't really
view him as a top ten pick rich I know
he's big and strong and all that I just
to me that a little early for me so I
couldn't endorse that if I was in the
charger situation
Daniel Jeremiah here in the Rich Eisen
show and then lastly the the early
favorite for deepest position in the
draft would be which wide receiver oh my
gosh wide receiver know this I mean
remember the year remember we had Odell
and Jarvis and Mike Evans and and all
those guys right this is going to be
just like that it is it is unbelievable
and that's even with a couple of these
guys going back to school but when we
get a chance at the combine and we get
to see you're gonna see you know rugs is
gonna run in the for twos this you know
ham or I don't know if you've seen him
from Penn State when you're watching
them he's gonna run potentially in the
for twos you know CD lamb I think is the
best one Jerry Judy's right there with
them you got a kid I you get Arizona
State a Pitman there at USC is a great
player a minute is a long long list of
receivers and if you look at
championship week and you got AJ Brown
okay you also obviously have DK Metcalfe
would have been but he had a terrific
season
Hartman you know Hardman had a big
return for Kansas City also showed up
dressed like LL Cool J so he's got the
swag going on and and Devo Devo Samuel
um what he's been able to add in the
second half of the season for the 49ers
has been particularly significant I
guess the the the Packers are the only
one that don't come in with a shiny
rookie wide receiving object into into
this weekend DJ yeah that's a great
point and these guys what we've seen is
in the past it used to be you know
you're never gonna see rookie receivers
very often see them have a big-time
impact because of the adjustment but now
as you're seeing the Saturday game blend
into the Sunday game and figuring out
ways to get these guys the ball and
bubble screens and fly sweeps and quick
hitters and and over-the-top Walczak
they've found a way to get a lot out of
these kids right away and we're gonna
see it in my opinion one of the best
groups we've ever seen in this upcoming
class DJ thanks
I'm appreciated also the update on on
the top 19 on the AP list for programs
appreciated that that update on Twitter
you should bring me over a welcoming
present as a new neighbor in the top 25
yeah you know what like I said
Michigan's 18 appstate 19 just keep it
down next door that's all we don't want
to hear from you okay I just saw Charles
at the practice this morning I don't
have to listen there were no others
receiving votes
I don't believe on that program tell
them that will you please tell them I
said thanks to the tide and you will see
on NFL Network and the coverage of
everything that's gonna be going down
from East West Shrine this weekend
that's on NFL Network all the way
through the draft on NFL Network for
more of the Rich Eisen show tune -
audience Channel - 39 on DirecTV for
free on BR Live or download the Rich
Eisen show app